how are you justin i'm good i'm great
did you get to meet uh charles barkley
in the hallway we just met he is
ignoring i feel i felt like uh like he
was shaking like a baby's hand right
like in his head he was like this is
what it feels like to meet like an
injury he is a large man did you get any
uh
tips are you an athletic fellow i don't
really know clearly yes i don't know i
i don't know you might be uh amazing uh
i i'm i'm great at squash squad um no i
i was i i was always uh i was pretty bad
at sports i loved playing sports that
was the problem but i was i just had no
athletic prowess i remember playing
basketball and uh and the kids on the
other team would would do a fake
countdown clock like i was very neurotic
about the shot clock right how much time
you have yes the second i would touch
the ball there'd be like 40 seconds left
in the clock and they would all go three
two one and i would just like huck it
from like that down the court you never
want to listen to your opponents on that
one yeah right and i remember i remember
like praying to god like literally
praying to god that the ball wouldn't be
passed to me like i would i would hide
around like defenders to avoid like i
would like call off passes from the ball
i don't know like dear lord you don't
want to do that
i said a lot of that in school you don't
want to go this way
i'm just here to look around
now uh you've been working a lot
recently on uh helping voter
registration drives yeah trying to get
young people registered that's right
i've been going up to new hampshire a
lot because it's a very important swing
state up there and uh trying to get kids
to uh to college kids to register and um
i actually got to meet
uh barack obama i got to meet him did
you what was that like did you enjoy uh
meeting him it was it was really amazing
actually it was like uh sort of
this sounds really cheesy and bizarre
but it was kind of a moving experience
it was sort of uh and he was so so like
magnetic and and cool he just was like
like i wanted to hang out with him i
felt like afterwards i was like is that
it we do we get to like party and hang
out
i was like he probably doesn't want to
party at this point
a week to go and he blew it with a crazy
crazy kegger with justin
yeah
this is awesome
click
uh sorry america yeah but i got really
like bashful and like like giggly i felt
like like a 12 year old girl meeting
like a jonas brother i got very like
like you know right and he said to me he
was like uh he goes to you uh he goes uh
the mad guy you're you're a cool guy
you're really cool you're cool guys
i'm that guy yeah and i said um i was
like well yeah thanks so you're pretty
cool too
and he said he said we should do a uh we
should do like a mac pc thing for the
campaign we should do one of those and i
said yeah okay and and then i was like
who then in the scenario would i be like
you're obviously much cooler than me so
are you the mankind would i be right i
didn't know quite what is uh right on
that one he probably didn't give it that
much thought right
we'll do that and it's in the works
right
gonna go be president now uh but
whatever never think about you again uh
now let's talk about the mac thing uh
do you you
the those ads are ubiquitous they're
everywhere they're always on you must
hear from people people must recognize
you constantly for those ads yeah is it
a good experience what's it like it's
it's usually um people the reaction is
usually
pretty indifferent like overwhelmingly
indifferent it's never like there's
never any real like excitement like oh
wow like that's like it's always like
there's a desk and there's a mug and oh
there's the mad guy and it's never
there's never in fact
at one point uh some i remember somebody
i was walking in new york and uh and
this guy just stopped in the middle of
the street and goes computer
computer
always nice to be recognized by a
caveman yeah
and it took me a while yeah get out
your house
um but it i was with my mom recently
walking around and somewhere some guy
was passing me and he said to his friend
like very audibly like
kind of yelled at he was like oh it's
the guy from those damn commercials
my mother is very proud always nice to
be with your mom at that moment exactly
now when you uh first visited our show
which is three years ago now at the time
you were living with uh jonah hill who
has since also gone on to bigger i think
we have a photo here of jonah hill there
he is
a dmv shot yeah you guys are
you guys are good friends and what was
it like when you lived together was that
he uh it was it was great he was he's
jonah's the best he's the funniest human
being in the world seems very sweet and
natural he's himself very down earth
great like i love him he's the best um
but i remember it's funny it's the first
time i did your show um his friend
jonah's friend uh came up to him and
said oh i saw your your friend justin
and conan show and you should tell me he
was you know i thought he was really
good and joan was like oh good i'll tell
him like i'll see him soon and he said
jon's friend said yeah it's just good to
see funny young asian actors working
and i said and jonah was like what are
you talking about he's not asian and his
friend was like yeah very funny but
seriously there's like john cho
and justin and like there's not a lot of
so there are people that think you're an
actor convinced and a couple days after
this experience i was we were the house
that we were living in was we lived on
this very quiet street in santa monica
and uh there was like a night like
banging on my door at one in the morning
like
and i and i put on my glasses and sort
of woke up shuffled to the door and well
first i woke up then i put on the
glasses uh sorry i i walked the door and
there were three santa monica police
detective like police officers on the
doorstep like banging on my door
and the santa monica police department
opened the door and uh and and i did i
was like what's the problem i knew
enough not to open the door right away i
said what seems to be the problem and
they said uh your car is blocking a
driveway and i said well what kind of
car is it they said well what kind of
car do you drive and i said i praise and
they're like it's a prius so i i open
the door and they they grab me and like
put me in handcuffs so they start to
arrest you they arrested me and they
were like right in my face like you shut
up we're gonna ask questions now and i
said what's what's the problem i was
weirdly not that freaked out i knew i
hadn't done anything wrong and they were
they were shining the light back and
forth from my face to this picture that
they were all conferring around and they
kept saying is your name david lens is
your name and i was like no no it's
justin long it's not david lentz and
like six or seven times they asked me
and finally they were like so you're
telling us that this isn't you and they
turned the picture around and shined the
light on the picture and it was a
mugshot of a fully asian man
i don't know like no no doubt about it
like short spiky hair
yeah this is you yeah yeah so there's
this weird sort of so now to this day
joan it's jonah's favorite running joke
is that any time he sees an asian person
it'll be like oh like this you're you're
that's your brother
good jonah
yeah now let's talk about this movie
let's make sure you mention this zach
and miri make uh make a porno you play a
gay porno actor in this movie guilty as
charged yes hi mom yeah
um
and uh we have a clip here we're pretty
much out of time but uh uh anything we
need to know for this clip i'm glad
we're almost out of time i'm gonna have
to tell this story about how i did
research extensive research for the role
um before you knew you had the role you
were doing
exactly come on hey this is that kind of
show and by the way
[Applause]
i'll get you and i'll get you
who am i to be right
i would like to say i would like to go
on record saying like sir charles
barkley is completely wrong i don't want
to live in a world without conan's
string dance thank you you're a good man
good thank you uh i think this is
equipped with um elizabeth banks and uh
seth rogen two of the funniest actors uh
working i think and um yeah so uh let's
take a look at this uh clip from zach
and murray make a porno
what do you do uh what brings you here
i'm an actor
wow that's really impressive thank you
thank you movies movies pretty much what
anything i've seen what what movies oh
all sorts of movies with all male casts
all mill casts like glen gary glen ross
like that
like
glenn and gary suck ross's meeting
is that like a sequel
sort of
somebody imagining
oh like the whiz
more erotic
and with
less women
no women to be exact
i apologize in advance if i am out of
line here but are you in porn guilty is
charged
the obama campaign will embrace you
right uh zach and mary make a porno
opens in theaters this friday justin
really cool having you on the show for
doing it